on va plus loin avec comme chaque lundi
à mes côtés Annie va reporter de guerre
indépendant bonjour Anne oui bonjour
Raphaël et Bruno Darou chroniqueur
internationale à France 24 bonjour
bonjour et un déluge de missiles c'est
donc abattu sur l'Ukraine visant des
cibles stratégiques comme les
infrastructures ou les centrales
électriques mais aussi des immeubles
d'habitation des objectifs clairement
civils ce qui fait dire à la France que
la Russie c'est à nouveau rendu coupable
de crimes de guerre écoutez Vladimir
Poutine se justifier juste après
l'accusation de volodières qui enverme
Moscou
le régime de Kiev c'est deux facto
alignés avec les formations terroristes
internationales avec les groupes les
plus odieux laisser de telles crimes
sans réponse n’est tout simplement plus
possible
dans la matinée d'aujourd'hui comme
suggéré par le ministère de la Défense
et en accord avec le plan établi par
l'état-major de la Russie une frappe
massive a été lancée avec des armes de
longue portée et de haute précision
depuis les airs la mère et la terre sur
les infrastructures de l'énergie du
commandement militaire et de
communication de l'Ukraine
on a affaire à des terroristes des
dizaines de missiles iraniens de type
shahides sont tirés
ils ont deux cibles nos infrastructures
d'énergie qui et les régions de l'eau
vive ni pro vénissia farkiv zapporja
soumis Rachid
ils veulent créer la panique et le chaos
ils veulent détruire le système
énergétique ils sont désespérés la
deuxième cible sont les civils
comment comprendre ce qui s'est passé
côté russe réaction désordonnée
désespéré ou bien escalade planifié
voulu par le Kremlin alors ça moi je ne
sais pas parce que je ne sais pas dans
les petits papiers du Kremlin en tout
cas ce qui est frappant c'est l'usage du
mot terroriste c'est-à-dire que
volimersky accuse bien sûr la Russie
aujourd'hui d'actes terroriste puisqu'il
s'agissait de bombardements envers des
civils c'est plus facile d'envoyer des
missiles que de faire modifier le front
mais samedi c'était le pont en Crimée et
Vladimir Poutine évidemment dès ce matin
à lui aussi utiliser ce mot
terroristique réagit toujours en miroir
et aujourd'hui il y a quand même
beaucoup de personnes en Russie qui sont
satisfaites et qu'il expriment depuis ce
matin que enfin une pluie de missiles ce
arrive sur l'Ukraine et en différents
points d'Ukraine il y a le président de
la Crimée le président prorus bien sûr
de la Crimée qui s'en fél et qui dit
d'ailleurs que si ça avait été le cas si
cette stratégie celle d'aujourd'hui
avait été la même depuis le début du 24
février la guerre se serait arrêtée
depuis le mois de mai et puis il y a
bien sûr évidemment kadirof qu'adirov
qui n'en perd pas une pour parler et qui
lui effectivement dit que il avait eu
quelques petits critiques on les avait
tout entendu la semaine dernière et les
jours précédents et que là aujourd'hui
il était satisfait à 100% de l'opération
antiterroriste
encore comme lui-même le réclamait oui
Moscou soleil ne pouvait pas ne pas
répondre un Bruno à l'explosion
qu'évoquea n'a survenu samedi sur le
pont de kercht en Crimée c'est presque
rassurant entre guillemets qu'il n'est
usait que d'armes conventionnelle oui
enfin bon rassurant vraiment avec
beaucoup de guillemets quand même parce
que pour les populations qui ont été
visées c'est quand même effectivement
très douloureux très très barbares oui
enfin rassurant dans le sens que c'était
pas d'autres types d'armes qui ont été
utilisées de ce point de vue oui
effectivement moi je pense que moi non
plus je suis pas dans les petits papiers
du Kremlin mais on sentait quand même
que vous la lumière Poutine il était un
peu sous pression ce qu'on appelle un
peu le
avec notamment Kadirov et puis il y a eu
quand même ce qui s'est passé sur le
pont de Kerch qui était quand même à la
fois la grande réalisation la grande
fierté de Vladimir Poutine qui dès
l'annexion de la Crimée avait ordonné la
construction de ce pot tout ça c'était
fait en à peine 4 ans donc c'est vrai
que c'était un déjà un très beau défi
architectural voilà qui avait été
réalisé et puis qu'il a plus
prosaïquement mais enfin c'est très
important assurer une partie évidemment
de l'alimentation logistique de l'armée
russe depuis la Russie vers la Crimée
pour remonter sur le franc Sud autour de
Carson donc oui c'était un très mauvais
coup il ne pouvait pas rester sans rien
faire parce que là avec ce qui s'était
passé samedi au pont de kerchs là s'il
n'avait rien fait assez vite alors là le
camp ultra-nationaliste lui serait tombé
dessus à bras raccourcis donc il était
obligé de faire quelque chose après ce
qu'on ne sait pas effectivement mais là
et les spécialistes ont des avis un peu
Diver en fait c'est si vraiment il a
utilisé cet incident pour procéder à ces
bombardements ou si c'est bombardements
étaient déjà planifié d'après c'est
d'après les Ukrainiens après les
services ukrainien ils avaient observé
des mouvements d'avions de navire de
porte-missiles
il y a déjà plusieurs jours avant début
octobre avant donc le grave incident qui
s'est produit sur le pont de kerchs et
donc à ce moment-là on serait dans une
stratégie d'escalade planifié par
Vladimir Poutine avec d'abord la
mobilisation partielle puis la séquence
qu'on vient de vivre les menaces
nucléaires là les bombardements
d'infrastructures énergétique
effectivement le fait de viser des
civils avec des bombardements assez
intensifs donc à ce moment-là finalement
on a presque envie de dire que la divers
Poutine aurait presque été content entre
guillemets de cet incident qui lui
donnait le prétexte
final pour procéder à ces bombardements
qui sont quand même parmi les plus
massifs depuis le début du conflit ça
pose tout de même la question de
l'épuisement des ressources militaires
russes aussi bien en homme qu'en
matériel oui on peut on peut se poser
cette question les militaires se la pose
on n'a pas de réponse c'est-à-dire
est-ce que la Russie va pas être à court
de munitions prochainement on voit bien
qu'elle a du mal à sans doute puisque le
on voit bien que là que ce qui est le
plus important ce sont les musiciens
puisque justement l'armée ukrainienne
depuis le départ et quand j'étais sur le
front au mois d'avril on me l'a répété
tous les jours et les militaires mes
sources ukrainiennes et elles le disent
à tout le monde elle répète à qui veut
l'entendre ce sont les munitions les
militaires Ukrainiens veulent des
munitions ils veulent qu'on leur donne
des munitions pas seulement des armes
mais surtout des munitions et bien sûr
côté russe on a besoin de munitions
également alors il semblerait que
justement les 80 et quel je crois que
c'est 84 missiles qui ont été envoyés
aujourd'hui sont justement des missiles
de fabrication soviétique donc
ne sont pas justement les missiles les
plus modernes ceux qui sont les plus
précis qui ont été utilisés ce sont les
précédents ce qui pourraient être
analysées par justement une peur de ne
pas avoir assez de ceux qui sont qui
sont capables de faire des frappes très
précises et d'utiliser ce ceux-là qui
ont été utilisés aujourd'hui qui n'ont
pas forcément été extrêmement précis
parce qu'on se demande pourquoi
justement un pont piétonnier en plein
milieu de Kiev a été frappé
chance il n'y avait personne mais en
tout cas ça n'était pas du tout une
structure militaire comme les Russes
disent comme d'habitude qu'il ne
ciblaient que des installations
militaires moi je voudrais souligner
juste une chose qui a dit Poutine ce
matin parce que c'est étonnant alors que
venir Poutine est sans cesse en train de
répéter que il est en train de se battre
contre et ça c'est une expression russe
nouvelle l'Occident collectif et bien ce
matin ce n'est pas ce qu'il a dit ce
matin il n'a absolument pas prononcé le
mot nid d'Occident ni de collectif c'est
à dire que ce matin il battait d'après
ses dires uniquement contre l'Ukraine et
ça c'est précisément je pense à cause de
ce qui s'est passé samedi à cause du
fait que il a été évidemment blessé dans
son amour-propre que ce pont ce symbole
comme Bruno vient de le dire était
endommagé il n'a pas été complètement
mais il a été quand même et du coup il a
un peu mis de côté c'est diatribe
habituelles contre l'Occident faisant
croire à tous sa population russe que
c'est l'Occident qui attaque la Russie
il ne l'a pas dit ce matin autre signe
tout de même d'escalade Bruno le
président biélorus Alexandre lucaschenko
masse des troupes lui à sa frontière
avec l'Ukraine en accusant qui Ève de
préparer une attaque contre son pays oui
alors là on est toujours un peu dans le
même dans la même rhétorique que celle
quasiment qui avait été utilisée par les
Russes au moment de l'opération
militaire spéciale comme ils disent
c'est une forme d'agression préventive
c'est-à-dire que l'ennemi l'ennemi
s'apprête à m'attaquer je suis menacé
donc bon avant avant qu'il arrive et ben
c'est moi c'est moi qui attaque
alors ce qui est un peu bizarre c'est
que le cash and Co il a été assez
belliqueux vraiment sur la ligne de
Poutine au début du conflit une partie
des troupes russes était stationnée
russe voilà et c'est de là qu'ils
étaient partis vers qui avec le succès
puis depuis c'était un peu silence radio
de la part de lucaschenko alors
maintenant visiblement il est sous
pression il est sous contrainte de
Poutine à qui il doit quand même d'être
encore aujourd'hui au pouvoir il faut
quand même rappeler qu'il y a eu des
manifestations très très importantes il
y a en 2020 donc oui ça il y a deux ans
[Musique]
détourner des avions avec à son bord des
opposants s'en souvient aussi voilà
absolument et donc il est fragilisé il
est redevable à Vladimir Poutine et
alors donc ça pose la question est-ce
que Vladimir Poutine en fait est-ce que
les Russes veulent reformer un front
nord comme ils l'ont fait au tout début
mais ça n'a pas marché parce qu'il
n'était pas suffisamment prêt
là est-ce qu'il sent qu'ils sont plus
près où est-ce qu'ils vont mettre des
efforts sur ce front pour recommencer
s'il faut à marcher sur Kiev pour un
interrogation personne n'en sait rien
mais enfin c'est quand même très bizarre
que lucaschenko disent ce qu'il vient de
dire là maintenant l'engagement biélorus
changerait la changerait un peu la phase
de ce conflit avec un nouveau front nord
parce que là on est vraiment on est au
nord de Kiev c'est la capitale qui
pourrait aussi si on regarde une carte
c'est au nord de l'Ukraine donc
effectivement si location n'a pas
précisé je ne sais pas si c'est
volontaire de sa part parce que c'est
peut-être du bluff on ne sait pas où
serait situé ce contingent
biélorus
donc je il n'a pas précisé mais
effectivement on n'est absolument sûr
d'une chose c'est que ça ne va pas
changer
la figure de la guerre c'est-à-dire
Raphaël n'est pas connu pour être une
armée extrêmement puis extrêmement
nombreuses donc si le Cush & Co a dit ce
qu'il a dit aujourd'hui c'est qu'il en a
été sans aucun doute obligé pour des
raisons qui lui sont propres qui sont
d'abord le fait qu'il est totalement le
vassal de venir Poutine depuis toujours
l'occasion est au pouvoir depuis avant
que Vladimir Poutine soit lui-même au
pouvoir le cacher c'est un leader
typique du soviétisme absolument
absolument mais est-ce que ça serait pas
plutôt pour montrer
réaffirmer cette alliance slave entre
les trois voisins alliance de laquelle
justement les Ukraine sont partis se
sont retirés depuis bien longtemps
puisque les Ukrainiens disent non nous
ne sommes pas vos voisins cela nous
sommes indépendants nous sommes en état
indépendants il faut nous reconnaître
comme tel donc est-ce que ça serait pas
justement pour idéologiquement se
montrer ce côté là juste après le prix
Nobel de la pêche je vous rappelle qui a
été la semaine dernière donnée à trois
ONG une biélorusse une Ukrainienne et
russe et ça c'est sans doute une fierté
pour le pouvoir Biélorussie
Bruno Darou alors la Russie a un allié
assez évident qui est la Biélorussie qui
jusqu'à présent en tout cas ne s'est pas
démenti même si voilà le latribution de
ce prix Nobel de la paix c'est une
fierté pour une partie en tout cas des
belles
qu'est-ce qu'il faut attendre du vote
qui doit avoir lieu là dans les
prochaines heures à l'Assemblée générale
des Nations unies puisque elle se réunit
à nouveau à propos de cette guerre et
que ça permet souvent de jauger du
rapport de force et notamment de la
capacité de Moscou à maintenir en tout
cas la neutralité d'un certain nombre
neutralité bienveillant d'un certain
nombre de pays il faut bien voir que là
effectivement c'est le là dans quelques
minutes ça va être là les débuts du
début des débats à l'Assemblée générale
de l'ONU dans la foulée de la résolution
la semaine dernière au Conseil de
sécurité de l'ONU sur l'annexion par la
Russie des quatre territoires Ukrainiens
en fait l'ONU aujourd'hui c'est indigné
par la voiture secrétaire général sur ce
qui s'était passé ce matin concernant
les bombardements russes sur plusieurs
villes d'Ukraine mais là les pays vont
commencer à s'exprimer puis à voter sur
le fait de condamner la Russie pour
l'annexion de ces quatre territoires
Ukrainiens alors effectivement c'est un
vote à l'assemblée générale qui n'a pas
puisque ça a été bloqué au Conseil de
sécurité par la Russie qui n'a pas force
exécutant absolument mais ce qui est
intéressant même du coup si ça va
prendre quelques jours ce sera dans le
courant de la semaine qu'on aura le vote
parce que chacun s'exprime ils vont
commencer dans dans 20 minutes ou un peu
moins maintenant
ce sera intéressant de voir de mesurer
le degré d'isolement ou pas de la Russie
il faut savoir que lorsqu'il y a eu deux
votes de l'assemblée générale depuis le
début de la guerre à chaque fois les
votes condamnant la Russie étant sur une
ligne pro-occidentale on va dire pour
simplifier schématiser on est autour de
130 140
il y a eu un vote ensuite où c'était
moins moins favorable où il y avait que
93 pour les pour les occidentaux donc là
tout l'enjeu c'est de savoir si on sera
en gros au dessus de 100 pays qui
condamne la Russie et autour de 130 140
ce serait très bien retrouverez le
niveau du début du conflit ou si on sera
en dessous et évidemment
là apparemment à l'ONU il y a beaucoup
de comment dire de lobbying ou de
pression sur les pays qui veulent
s'abstenir pour les faire basculer dans
le bon camp pour les occidentaux et dans
l'autre pour les Russes est-ce que les
Russes vont finalement se retrouver
comme lors des deux premiers votes avec
simplement quatre ou cinq pays autour
d'eux c'est à l'Érythrée la Corée du
Nord la Biélorussie le Venezuela voilà
où est-ce que ils auront un soutien un
peu plus important et même s'ils
arrivent à avoir le soutien de 15 ou 20
pays bah ce serait peut-être un
indicateur un peu inquiétant pour les
pour le con occidental en tout cas voir
si ceux qui vont s'abstenir seront les
mêmes que il y a quelques mois c'est
intéressant il y avait quand même eu une
trentaine voire 35 pays dont des pays
d'Afrique effectivement et puis pour
Vladimir Poutine c'est toujours la
preuve de que le monde n'est plus
bipolaire
et qu'il est multipolaire ça c'est la la
rhétorique de venir Poutine c'est son
obsession c'est de montrer que il n'y a
plus que deux pays qui comptent le RSS
qui n'existe plus et les États-Unis mais
il y a la Russie la Chine les États-Unis
et que donc certains pays dont ceux qui
se vote évidemment à l'Assemblée
générale de l'ONU peuvent prendre partis
pour les uns et pour les autres ça c'est
très important ça veut dire que le
libéralisme
occidental aux yeux de venir Poutine ne
serait plus le seul dominant existant
alors après ce qu'il dit pas c'est qu'à
l'intérieur de ce camp antioxydantal
évidemment tout n'est pas un parfum de
rose où tout le monde s'aime il y a des
compétitions en interne notamment entre
la Russie et la Chine et là pour le
moment c'est quand même la Chine qui est
la grande puissance vis-à-vis vis-à-vis
de la Russie personne la Chine ne mène
pas une guerre en Ukraine et puis il y a
une économie beaucoup beaucoup
absolument mais comme la Russie est en
train de mener une guerre en Ukraine
aujourd'hui la Russie est en même temps
fragilisée on le voit tous mais aux yeux
sans doute devenir Poutine puisque c'est
lui qui a commencé cette guerre il l'a
voulu montrer son pouvoir en commençant
cette guerre et il est il est encore
persuadé et puis le pouvoir gagné
contradictoire de la lumière Poutine
c'est effectivement il est favorable un
monde alternatif multipolaire etc mais
en même temps son obsession c'est que
les États-Unis le considère lui son pays
la Russie égale à égal comme une grande
puissance et presque lui tout seul on a
envie de dire avant du temps et les
discours en tout cas d'Emmanuel Macron
et de Joe Biden à l'Assemblée annuel des
Nations Unies sur les non alignés pour
les enjoindre à rejoindre le camp
occidental et a condamné la Russie
ont-ils porté ses discours la réponse
dans les prochaines heures en tout cas
début de réponse ce sera à suivre en
tout cas sur France 24 pour les discours
de l'Ukraine et de la Russie vous serez
avec nous Bruno merci beaucoup Anne
c'était on va plus loin rester avec nous
on se retrouve dans trois minutes pour
un nouveau journal d'en parler